[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing harry dumbledore
voldemort and the epic jewel in the
ministry atrium from the order of the
phoenix
i have nothing more to say to you potter
he said quietly
you have irked me too often for too long
avada kadavra
harry had not even opened his mouth to
resist his mind was blank his wand
pointing uselessly at the floor
but the headless golden statue of the
wizard in the fountain had sprung alive
leaping from its plinth to land with a
crash on the floor between harry
and voldemort the spell merely glanced
off its chest as the statue flung at its
arms to protect harry
what cried voldemort staring around and
then he breathed
dumbledore harry looked behind him his
heart pounding
dumbledore was standing in front of the
golden gates now at first glance
this scene seems like what you'd expect
harry is in mortal danger
and dumbledore who has looked over harry
for most of his life
intervenes and protects him from the
fatal projectile that was heading toward
him
however what's interesting about this is
that by this point in time
dumbledore was fully aware of
voldemort's horcruxes and he was also
fully aware of the fact
that at some point or another harry had
to die additionally
in order for the prophecy to be
fulfilled and for voldemort to be
defeated
voldemort had to be the one to initially
kill harry since dumbledore knew all
about the prophecy
one question that should be addressed
here is why not let voldemort kill harry
right then
and there though dumbledore cares for
harry it's made painfully clear in the
books and films that his number one
priority is the fate of the wizarding
world
and defeating voldemort not saving harry
so
again why did dumbledore even bother
saving harry from the killing curse
why not let him die and get one step
closer to defeating the dark lord the
truth is that dumbledore wanted harry
alive
so that he could use him i thought all
these years
that we were protecting him for her for
lily
we have protected him because it has
been essential to teach him
to raise him to let him try his strength
said dumbledore
his eyes still tight shut dumbledore
opened his eyes
snape looked horrified you have kept him
alive so that he can die at the right
moment
don't be shocked severus how many men
and women have you watched to die
lately only those whom i could not save
said snape
he stood up you have used me meaning
i have spied for you and lied for you
put myself immortal danger for you
everything was supposed to be to keep
lily potter's son safe now you tell me
you've been raising him
like a pig for slaughter raising him
like a pig for sorter is such a powerful
line
and this whole exchange is powerful
because it really brings to the surface
the true motivations of dumbledore
at the time the beloved and pure school
headmaster
though dumbledore genuinely cared for
harry he did always know that harry was
going to have to die one day
and the reason he didn't let him die in
the ministry atrium was because there
were still more horcruxes to be
destroyed
and donald needed harry to search for
them harry's unique connection to
voldemort
gave him an edge over others when it
came to tracking them down
and by having harry do it it also meant
that no other lives would be put in
danger
dumbledore's betrayal was almost nothing
of course there had been a bigger plan
harry had simply been too foolish to see
it he realized that now
he had never questioned his own
assumption that dumbledore wanted him
alive
now he saw that his lifespan had always
been determined by how long it took
to eliminate all the horcruxes
dumbledore had passed the job of
destroying them to him
and obediently he'd continue to chip
away the bonds tying not only voldemort
but himself to life how neat how elegant
not to waste any more lives but to give
the dangerous task to the boy
who had already been marked for
slaughter and whose death would not be a
calamity
but another blow against voldemort and
dumbledore had known that harry would
not duck out
that he would keep going to the end even
though it was his end
because he had taken trouble to get to
know him hadn't he
dumbledore knew as voldemort knew that
harry would not let anyone else die for
him
now that he had discovered it was in his
power to stop it
the images of fred lupin and tonks lying
dead in the great hall
forced their way back into his mind's
eye and for a moment he could hardly
breathe
death was impatient as harry was the
perfect weapon for dumbledore to use
against voldemort
it would have made no sense at all to
allow harry to die sooner
if dumbledore wanted harry dead he could
have arranged that at almost any
point he kept him around to find and
destroy horcruxes
and that's about it allowing him to die
in the order to phoenix would have only
made his ultimate goal
more difficult and that's it for this
video if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time
you're a wizard howdy
[Music]
you